uh let me ask you from the interviewer
seat so I get to do this podcast and I
often have to think about giving a large
platform and having a conversation with
very controversial figures
and the the level of controversy has
been slowly increasing uh what's the
role
of this medium to to you
oh this medium of speech between two
people and me speaking with a
controversial figure me or some other
interviewer what's the role of uh giving
platform to controversial figures say
members of the KKK or dictators
um
people who are seen as evil well we want
to face the world with reality
and the reality is that there is some
unpleasantness
unpleasantnesses in the world you know
running from genocide right through to
ordinary discrimination
um to offensiveness it's the real world
as we we know it exists are we afraid to
say it
do we want to make people think that we
live in a world where those words are
not used where those animosities don't
exist
um the answer is no but you can
whitewash you can normalize the use of
those words you can whitewash the uh
acceptability of certain leaders so for
example interviewing Hitler in 1938 1935
1936 1937 38 those are all different
Dynamics there but you can normalize
this person and in so doing create
enormous harm well see I don't see it as
normalized I see it as exposing
if more people had taken one comp
seriously
um Franklin Roosevelt would have acted
much sooner
he only got us into the war as Congress
hears into the war when the Japanese
made the mistake of attacking Pearl
Harbor
but there were some people in the state
department there were some people in the
administration who were trying trying to
get Roosevelt to see what Hitler was
really like and he was blind to it and
this was one of the greatest presidents
the United States ever had he was blind
to it until the Japanese attacked Pearl
Harbor
so I think that words unpleasant ideas
as expressed by words are essential for
communicating fact and truth and reality
and that's why I think that we should
not whitewash language we should not
whitewash the fact that Jeffrey Epstein
was pretty close to MIT and Harvard and
Harvard
um and um your reality reality actually
means something yeah but from the role
of the interviewer that's something I
have to think a lot about whether
interviewing Hitler you said exposing
I think
it's hard to know what Hitler's like in
a room but
it's also hard to know I've never met
Jeffrey ever since cartoon know what
Jeffrey Epstein is like in a room but I
imagine to some degree they're
charismatic figures
so exposing them in the interview
setting is not an easy task
well interviewing is not an easy all
right job yeah
um it's it's not a good idea to have an
interview with be an idiot
hey
I know exactly what you're saying and I
know why you're looking at me directly
as you say it I appreciate that Harvey